you've got fat shows your muscles you'll
be a soldier you remember me at 16 all I
wanted to do was crack skulls and [ __ ]
girls I'm not trying to honor you I'm
trying to get you to run my kingdom
while I eat drink and [ __ ] my way to an
early grave
God's this is country will you say just
you and me on the kingsroad swords at
our sides a couple of tavern wenches to
warm our beds tonight you'd have asked
me 20 years ago it was that one Oh what
was her name not common dear Leo's back
there with a great big tits you could
bury your face in Bessie she was one of
yours
Bessie thanked their gods for Bessie and
their tits
she's as wild as that animal of hers I
want to punish that would you have me do
whip her through the streets Joffrey
will bear these scars for the rest of
his life you let that little girl disarm
you I knocked him down with a hammer
God's I was strong then caved in his
breastplate they never tell you how they
all [ __ ] themselves
Lance oh gods what a stupid name who
named you some half-wit with a stutter
it's empty
your grace you mean it's empty there's
no more wine that one empty means so get
more foster mind the door while your
king eats and drinks and shits and [ __ ]
been sitting here for days start the
damn joust before I piss myself
your mother was a dumb [ __ ] with a fat
ass did you know that it's all fat for
your armor fat is that how you speak to
your king
always funny is it no you're great no
you don't like the hands joke it's all
[ __ ] in the poor boy you were the hand
the King's too fat for his armor go find
the breastplate stretcher Wow
drink I'm not thirsty drink you King
commands it an inspiring sight for the
people they come bow before your king
bow your shits the [ __ ] is pregnant
you're speaking of murdering a child
Seven Kingdoms Cyril 110 Seven Kingdoms
do you think it's honor that's keeping
the peace it's fear fear and blunt and
we're no better than the Mad King house
damn you are done with you Winterfell
Dothraki don't sail every child knows
that they don't have discipline they
don't have armor they don't have siege
weapons it's a neat little trick you do
you move your lips and your father's
voice comes out what do you want
sometimes I don't know what holds it
together our marriage you'll have to sit
on the throne while I'm away you'll
hates it more than I do
back in our day you weren't a real man
until you'd [ __ ] one girl for each of
the Seven Kingdoms and the Riverlands we
used to call it making the eight those
were some lucky girls you ever make the
eight Barristan no no believe so your
grace those were the days
on the funeral feast to be the biggest
the kingdom's ever saw and I want
everyone to taste the boar that got me
King Robert Baratheon murdered by a pig